déjà qu'on est dans une ville du caire
dans un quartier de ker et vous votre
idée c'est de regrouper tous ses fois
ensemble
c'est ça votre projet pour nous c'est ça
mon ami qui joue si sa valeur pure un
jour sur le casting de la vie scolaire
ils se plaignent à mâcon pas de moi
c'est à 5 me faut prendre le train c'est
une aire jetons la peine d'aller tout
seul tu vas-y où j'étais à galérer à
cette époque du coup je trouve asile
bien on y va on y va ensemble
j'arrive au local de 2,5 me et à jerry's
quatrième temps le scénar original moi
je suis pas là pour ça je suis là pour
mon pote laissez moi tranquille avec
votre truc de cinéma pour moi c'était un
milieu où fallait être fils d'acteurs
fils de réalisateurs ou vraiment
connaître quelqu'un et du couvent à la
dérogation qu'elle a un peu insisté elle
a fini par mettre ton pote en donnant
les répliques
je dis bah si c'est pour aider mon pote
votre truc là je vais le faire et voilà
bas de trois semaines après fabien mais
dumont rappeler on s'est revus plusieurs
fois jusqu'au jour où l'on sait que je
vais y aller
yanis tu cherches au koala tu veux te
faire exclure direct dès le début de
l'année c'est ça mais je te préviens moi
j'ai pas de lâcher l'athée sur une
mauvaise pente et c'est trop dommage
parce que moi je sais que tu vaux mieux
que ça et si je vais aller pas mieux que
ça
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'on a bien aimé nos années
collège et qu'on a bien rigolé qu'on
voulait en faire un film drôle et en
même temps parce que l'éducation est un
thème qui nous intéresse qui nous
interrogent et que l'éducation notamment
dans ces quartiers populaires voilà
c'est un thème qui on avait envie de
traiter le plus le plus sérieusement
possible derrière toute la déconne de la
cour de récréation ce que tu prof de
maths un moment dans le film il dit à
samia enseigné à saint denis s'est pas
vraiment commencé ni ailleurs et c'est
vrai il ya des particularités a enseigné
dans ces quartiers là ce qu'on voulait
surtout mettre en avant c'est que dans
ces quartiers là malheureusement le
contexte il est plus fort qu'eux
que la volonté des êtres humains voilà
dire que lacroix simon n'a voulu ni cap
et sur les preuves qui sont les parents
d'élèves mais sur les élèves on se rend
compte que tout le monde
monter mais le système est fait de telle
sorte que malheureusement même avec la
meilleure volonté du monde et des
enfants qui sont en décrochage scolaire
et des enfants qui sont dans une impasse
c'est de saison on voulait pas
[Musique]
cette volonté parce que tout de suite
quand tu commences à écrire tu
t'imagines des lieux et tout de suite
avec fabian s'imaginer ce collège je
voulais un collègue qui soit très proche
d'une cité en fait voilà parce que on
pense qu'à la fois le quartier influence
le collège le collège influence le
quartier voilà les frontières entre les
deux sont sont poreuses et ça on voulait
vous voulez le mettre en avant et on
voulait en plus à intégrer des gens du
quartier donc de francs moisins dans ce
projet
de notre côté
des choses
centre qu'elle est une enfant
mais avec tout
plaît chez les élèves
du quartier comment
faire l'amour
c'est un partenariat d'être
d'utiliser leur collège qu'avec l'équipe
de direction
gonis au super et puis après énormément
de gamins du collège vous rendez dans le
film mais moins
une centaine de gamins qui ont été ou
acteurs ou figurants dans le film donc
c'est vraiment leur film est donc là
d'être là dans le gros cinéma à 100
mètres de chez eux puisque va on est
juste deux côtés de la passerelle et la
cité 3 1 est juste derrière
c'était essentiel qui voit le film dans
ces conditions là avant tout le monde
[Musique]
je pense qu'on irait voilà on dirait je
pense que vous viendrez avait que deux
délégations de profs qui pèse quand même
le mieux le terrain que nous on a on a
nos souvenirs qu'après on a étudié le
terrain on est allé dans des bureaux de
cp on a passé des heures des journées
dans le collège après personne connue le
terrain que ceux qui bossent toute
l'année tous les jours et a évidemment
des moyens bien plus importants à m on
sait qu'il ya des efforts de fès pour ça
que c'est l'intérêt pourrait plus mais
on sait qui rend les moyens sont
vraiment très insuffisant
voilà donc les moyens la formation et
puis peut-être continuer à revaloriser
le métier de professeur qui est souvent
encore un petit peu je vous dévalué
qu'un titre voilà que à l'époque dans
les villages touchés pas de quoi c'était
le c'était c'était vraiment un métier
très très nerveux il enseignait le
savoir ils passaient savoir aux gamins
et où aujourd'hui on dit ou prof souvent
qu'ils sont feignants qui et c'est vrai
qu'ils sont mal payés etc
voilà je pense le à l'école c'est celle
à venir de tous nos enfants de toute
notre notre humanité donc faudrait
peut-être y mettre les moyens
conséquents